I will welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey how are you better than I deserve
what's up well I am I've got kind of a
two-part question I'm divorced and I
have two kids we have shared custody and
I know the value of your program and so
I'm wanting to instill some of that into
my kids and first of all we have decided
that they won't they've won and they've
come to me and said that they want
allowance and so I said that's fine what
I wanted them to do is to present to me
how much they think they should earn for
doing the tours and what they would do
in order to earn that and that sort of
thing present that to me so that I know
that they really want it well that was
two years ago and they're completely
unmotivated okay I don't know if I
should I have a nine year old in a
twelve year olds and how long much time
do they spend with you they're with me
about three days a week no about half
time okay yeah all right well I mean we
can't control what happens at Mom's
house you can coordinate with her to the
extent that she wants to participate but
obviously you've learned by now that you
don't run things over there
so no uncertain terms but so at your
house it's a way it would sound if it's
if I were in your shoes is boys and
girls here's the thing I'm your dad and
my job is to give you the tools to make
it out there in the big bad world and so
I'm going to give you those tools the
tools include brushing your teeth so you
have some they include bathing they
include going and doing your homework so
that you actually have basic knowledge
of graduating from high school so that
you can go on and get a better education
so you have to do certain things here
that I make you do because I love you
and because I'm preparing you to be an
adult one of those things is handling
money and there are four components to
handling money and we're going to do
this together
and it's going to be fun or you can
choose to not make it fun but you're
still going to do it so we might as well
make it fun the four components are work
give save and spend and so we're gonna
sit down here tonight and we're gonna
make out a list of what you're gonna do
around here for work and I'm doing this
not because I need work done but because
I want to teach you to work adults that
don't know how to work or what known is
worthless and I'm not raising those
kinds of adults my job as your dad is to
give you the tools to win out there and
work is one of those tools so you're
gonna do some things around here the
good news is when you do those things
your own commission we don't do
allowance allowances welfare we do
Commission work get paid don't work
don't get paid okay so you're gonna do
these things and you're gonna make a
list of them and if you don't do them
one week I'm not gonna punish you and
I'm not gonna yell at you you're just
not gonna get paid if you don't do them
for two weeks and I'm not gonna punish
you I'm not gonna yell at you you're
just not gonna get paid the third week
you don't do them I'm gonna make you do
them because you're going to learn to do
things and hold responsibility at nine
and twelve they can totally grasp this
conversation do you agree yeah okay
then once they make some money it's in
their hands now comes the fun part
we give some of it we save some of it
and we spend some of it and you can
decide and we'll talk that through
together I don't want you to do all of
it in one of those categories I want you
to do some in each category and you can
break it up however you want so what do
you want to save for and what do you
want to spend on and where do you want
to give it and how much and so around
our place you could do those something
like five it doesn't have to be a lot of
money it's representative because
they're not really worth anything the
work they're doing is not valuable
feeding the dog is not something you
would hire somebody to do you know
cleaning out the dishwasher is not
something you would hire somebody to do
mowing the grass might be but you know
the rest of them you know there's not
much to it so anyway we did stuff like
five dollars for five chores you got a
dollar a chore right and you know our
kids would give a dollar and they would
save two dollars and spend two dollars
each week
and we'd have payday on Sunday night you
know when we sit down and put a little
dry erase board on the refrigerator
check the chores off if you did them you
got all $5 if you only did four you got
$4.00 but you're always always going to
give some always going to save something
always gonna spend some and we had three
little humble ups
I give envelope and spend envelope and a
save envelope for them to put that money
in and so it's five one dollar bills and
you can do $10 but I don't care but
break it up into small denominations so
they can spread it out into these
different things and these guys are old
enough that you can even start to talk
about how you're saving for your car and
in our case I don't know about you where
you are well financially but in our case
we were able to to match whatever they
saved and so we called their savings
account 401 Dave because there they got
a match on it for their car and so
whatever you save two thousand dollars
I'll put two thousand dollars with it
when you're 16 you'll get you a four
thousand dollar car that's a great first
car you know a lot nicer car than my
first car well actually not about the
one I got but anyway like you see what
I'm saying that you can have start to
have some savings goals and lay that
stuff out there and it's not going to be
perfect and you have a little grace
around it and we're not Pharisees but
it's just like you know I told you to
brush your teeth you didn't brush your
teeth I did well how come a toothbrush
it and wet now you now we got a lying
problem and a toothbrush problem you
know and this is dispiriting goodness
yes oh yeah you know we're just we're
constantly expecting inspecting what we
expect inspecting what we expect and
we're not you know every little thing we
don't drill down and kill everybody on
every detail there's a lot of grace a
lot of mercy these are children they're
not sin that we're not sending them to
the salt mines but we also want them to
learn these skills their valuable skills
to learn to work to learn to be a giver
generosity is generous people are the
best people on the planet savers that
are the ones that get the things they
want and spenders that spend wisely
money that they earn by the sweat of
their brow spend differently and so
that's the system we use and I'll send
it to you it's called financial peace
Junior it's a box of teaching aids as
little dry erase board as three
envelopes has the instructions and I'll
send you a set of that for your
Christmas present
and um and Kelly sent them the the
second child piece - there's another
thing that the second set of envelopes
of the made that's the add-on for that
on kid thing we got a supplemental piece
for if you've got more than one kid so
we'll send you that that way they got
something to open on Christmas morning
and you can just begin the discussion
that's part of your new year thing or
whatever but I just framed it that way I
framed it like I did a lot of stuff
around our house you know as we're
Christians and we go to church on Sunday
and that's not a decision you get to
make as long as you live there you're
just you're gonna go I mean we're not
mad about what I mean but you know I'm
gonna sleep in today no yeah not unless
you sleep somewhere else this is why
because a spiritual walk is a
requirement in your life to have a
high-quality life and I want you to have
a high-quality life not because I'm a
big bad dad that's not going to do with
it my whole goal is to make you into the
best possible you you can be so you can
leave and stand on your own two feet and
we have these discussions about every
portion of our lives all the way through
and you know including sassing your
mother and so on all of that stuff
but you can tell folks I'm a dinosaur
father our children turned out because
of the fear of their father and the
nurture of their mothers
[Laughter]